Bernard ok est-ce que tu as quelque
chose à me demander c'est pas vous
demander moi je demande l'absolution
parce que au début j'ai commencé à vous
sucer un peu mais il est vrai dans
l'émission mais il est vrai qu'il y a
tellement de suceurs ici que j'ai décidé
d'arrêter de d'accord donc voilà je vous
demande de me pardonner de cela pour
cette nouvelle année d'accord donc plus
de ça
[Rires]
merci Valérie alors Cyril c'est pour
vous je demande l'absolution à vous
Cyril Hanouna pour le fait de dire
régulièrement dans cette émission que
vous avez un yacht j'ai trois villas moi
je le dis régulièrement je vous demande
l'absolution parce qu'en fait je me suis
complètement trompé vous avez trois
yacht et 5 villes
d'ailleurs on va en parler avec Patrick
Sébastien Talence qui parle de moi dans
son livre il parle de l'argent à la
télévision Sébastien dans ce livre où il
dit énormément de choses et c'est vrai
qu'il y a un passage où il parle de moi
que je vous lirai tout à l'heure au côté
de Patrick
Berger Allemand Castaldi Bernard
je vous demande la solution parce que
j'ai fait une fois dans ma vie un énorme
mensonge je vous ai menti pourquoi il y
a 2 ans et demi un élément type parce
que je vous ai dit que lundi et mardi je
ne serai pas là pour des raisons
médicales et en fait j'avais rendez-vous
à Los Angeles à la warnette je vous jure
que c'est vrai et en fait donc pris un
avion le dimanche et le lundi j'avais
rendez-vous à Los Angeles et je sors du
rendez-vous à 13h 9h en plus il est 10h
et là je vois sur mon téléphone Cyril
Hanouna et là c'est comme ça et
j'entends tu es où bah je dis bah je
t'ai dit Cyril tu vois là j'ai des
problèmes médicaux c'est la demain sinon
je te vire et j'étais Los Angeles non
c'est pas vrai elle est énorme alors là
je voulais que là j'étais comme ça et en
fait non je regarde la montre il était
13h je suis parti directement à
l'aéroport j'ai laissé mes affaires à
l'hôtel j'ai tous laissé mais enfin j'ai
pris le premier avion il restait qu'une
personne en première non et voilà
[Applaudissements]
le mardi matin
mais je n'ai jamais été en autant en
Shrek parce que je ne manque jamais et
en plus j'ai monté à mon patron
et en plus j'ai dit il va voir que la
sonnerie elle est pas quand on appelle à
l'étranger je suis mort je suis mort je
suis mort j'étais comme ça c'est la
seule fois que j'ai menti franchement
vous m'auriez donné de l'argent de la
première je vous aurais pardonné c'est
vrai franchement quel niveau bah alors
moi à l'inverse de Bernard je vous ai
pas assez sucer
la semaine commence bien je promets que
ça va changer
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît merci oui gilbertet je
vous demande l'absolution Cyril parce
qu'aujourd'hui je voulais m'excuser de
tous mes emportements auprès de Mathieu
Delormeau mais il n'est pas là mais il
n'est pas là la rumeur disait qu'il
était en tournage et la vraie
information c'est qu'elle est en weekend
tout frais payé sur les îles grecques
sachez-le j'avais l'info ah je m'en
doutais
des sanctions vont bien entendu tomber
vous le savez bien sûr vous a dit qu'il
était qui travaillait je l'ai cramé je
sais très bien qu'il est sur les îles
bien sûr voilà non mais je le sais
t'inquiète pas et encore une fois
l'ignominieuse trahison et abandon du
lundi encore une fois il n'est pas là
donc je voulais l'absolution je vous la
demande plus jamais je ne m'excuserai
auprès de leurs mots
toi tu arrives en retard tu bois tu en
as plus rien à [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
il a pris une tête
sans déconner hein vous dites rien dites
rien oui toi alors je voulais vous
demander là-dessus Cyril parce que avant
les vacances vous souvenez je suis venu
chez vous après une soirée mais on était
plusieurs et je dois vous avouer quelque
chose j'ai pas pu me retenir j'ai tu as
pété dans votre chemin peut-être dans
mon salon
j'ai trouvé le chemin après quelques
kilomètres mais j'ai trouvé
[Applaudissements]
et c'est pas vrai en plus ma chambre est
tout de suite à droite à gauche
[Rires]
j'ai voulu garder un petit souvenir je
l'ai emmené en vacances à Royan comme ça
vous étiez un petit peu avec moi mais je
pense que ça doit vous manquer
maintenant donc je vous le rends voilà
excusez-moi vraiment
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
dans votre loge en fait il y a deux il y
a une particularité il faut savoir dans
la loge des chroniqueurs on a des fruits
pourris tout moisi tout déglingué et
quand on arrive dans votre loge c'est
sublime il y a des corbeilles avec des
frites gorgées gros gonflés
[Applaudissements]
régulièrement des raisins des bananes
des noix de cajou et voilà ça fait 6 ans
que je vole des fruits régulièrement
vous allez
payeriez non je vous pardonne je vous
offrir je vous ai envoyé une corbeille
de fruits
celle de la loge chronique
vous inquiétez pas soit alors si c'est
comme chipie
c'est la chipie du PAF là qui parle là
hein je vous demande votre absolution
parce que depuis 2 ans j'ai un petit
rituel avant chaque émission vous le
savez c'est que je renifle une chemise
en fait ça m'aide à trouver un sens à ma
vie et à sentir l'odeur du succès tout
simplement et en fait l'autre jour je
sais pas ce qui m'a pris j'étais dans
une mauvaise passe j'avais besoin
d'amour et j'ai dérobé une de vos
chemises je l'ai emmené chez moi et je
dors avec tous les soirs depuis je fais
de très beaux rêves donc vraiment je
vous demande pardon et si je peux vous
sucer pour me rattraper ce sera avec
grand plaisir
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est-ce que tu veux alors moi je
voudrais vous demander pardon pardon
pour toutes les fois où je suis passé
chez vous et que j'ai fait croire au
service de sécurité que vous étiez au
courant de me prêter une voiture quand
j'avais été en galère de voiture ah oui
je passais les voir et je leur dis il me
faut une voiture Cyril au courant je
dois le récupérer à telle ou tel endroit
et je partais avec une voiture souvent
il me passait à Laguna je leur demandais
d'autres voitures qui me passaient pas
les autres voitures et je voudrais vous
demander pardon parce que la mascarade a
assez duré et je dis à tout le monde que
j'arrête de prendre des voitures
j'arrête de prendre un Laguna et
d'autres et d'autres voitures j'en ai
pris une ou deux une ou deux fois
j'ai pris un autre SUV électrique
hybride
électrique hybride électrique qui brille
j'essaye de vous aider
que j'ai pris le V8 turbo je vous dis
que j'ai pris
[Applaudissements]
c'est une double carburation qui pollue
pas du tout j'ai un hybride la moi je
suis en hybride
il y a pas de photo là par contre
personne vous pourrez il a raison Smart
électrique quand je suis en trottinette
personne ne prend en photo quand on me
prête malencontreusement
il y a des photos
[Applaudissements]
mais n'importe quoi
de plus on altruisme me tuera je vous le
dis quoi